[Music]
Over the course of the winter in
Wyoming, cold temperatures, freezing
rain, snow, mud, and windchill are all
possible. Livestock producers use many
tactics to ensure survival. Three of the
most significant include weather
forecasting, feeding strategy, and
protection from the wind. Weather
forecasting plays an important role in
winter livestock production. The
National Weather Service produces a cold
weather advisory for newborn livestock,
which can be found on their website.
This and other weather reports allow
producers to increase feed, move
livestock, or take other precautions
against the weather. Livestock's
nutritional requirements increase with
colder weather. If there is a windchill,
this increase can be dramatic. Most
researchers agree that 20 to 32 degrees
Fahrenheit is the lowest temperature dry
animals can withstand with no increase
in energy needs. Energy can be provided
to animals with extra hay or
supplements. Furr, it sure is cold out
here today. Almost every pasture you see
will have some mechanism for breaking
the wind. The horses behind me are able
to get behind this tree row to help them
withstand the windchill. From the
University of Wyoming Extension, I'm Ash
Legaros. Exploring the nature of
Wyoming.
[Music]